all right so what we should do is we
should perform right here you shouldn't
fight them up by the entrance because
those two entrances go to the same place
you know what I mean
we should funnel them yeah look at the
map you see uh will block off the wall
immediately left to that castle and then
they'll both have to come through that
same channel you see where I'm talking
about the stairs no no yeah
wait we may be talking about the same
thing I don't know okay so yeah just
follow me you like my skin first you
like it Hey hey babe hey pretty little
BAM okay so so we'll put put a guardian
there we're gonna wall this off honey so
right here is gonna be walls you know
what I mean yeah we don't need to do it
immediately because these guys are going
to come this way anyway so we can just
start putting traps in here this will be
like the kill room so I block off like
right here they've got to go through it
no no no you don't want to block them
off because then they'll break the wall
they won't break the wall if you do
anything else so yeah so you want to
like create a maze for them to go
through yeah this is a wall this is a
wall plate okay put on this wall yeah
that's fine this is good enough to start
with because we can hit them with our
with our own stuff first and then we can
hit them hard later that's true okay
ready so then then we got a lot longer
to go and we can retreat you're going to
hit you can pepper them from a distance
and then back up towards the gate
towards the kill zone you know in a milk
cake it's breaking through a gate
ah here we are hehehe
there we go that stuff that's the good
stuff
that's good one
oh yeah oh yeah that's a murder hole all
right mr. picah that's okay
oh boy it got me good all right but
that's good enough see we want to like
try to not use all of our [ __ ] and get
as many combos as possible because
combos will give us more money in the
long run so we want to like focus all of
our ability right on the right on where
we need to go make sense yep one change
already
yeah well that's fast we didn't even get
it last time what a bunch of losers
we're not fighting they're great no no
no just leave it it's one of their D
buffs so what we're going to do is we're
going to continue this chain we're just
going to I'm just going to place more oh
I'm gonna do I'll do the ceiling problem
if you can wall them all the way back
here I can put up a thing it doesn't
yeah okay I'll let me see I I have one
enough for one more wall I'm debating if
a long one would be better we'll bring
them back around we'll do one more back
loop before we go there so remember here
and pepper them you don't stand on a
barricade by the way that's that's also
not it'll they'll hit the barricade if
you do that oh man I like this wall try
back here I know right
yeah I get hit by my purple junk oh yeah
this is a good stuff business out yes
smart it up whoo makes sense all right
that's okay we were prepared for that
bit time yes we were save your money
try not to plant any more traps down
because I'm pretty sure we can get
through this with just these oh [ __ ]
they got range there's your range guys
watch out for those oh [ __ ] they've
damaged my barricade I don't know when
they did that [ __ ] that's is that it
broke on oh they broke mine yeah how
they do that
how'd they do that okay either way it
looks like we're going to get one more
I'm gonna try to replace this yeah why
did they damage that they're not
supposed to do that that was not how
those supposed to work either replace on
the other side yeah just try to stand in
front of them and not because they only
hit those if well hello what the hell
these guys come from go on step on those
barricades don't do it you keep doing it
don't do it okay go away you can destroy
those slow things oh okay yeah I suppose
damaging the one earlier okay there's
more stuff
oh it's a shield Bears don't worry about
that don't stand on the mercury you keep
doing it you keep stepping on it
occasionally it's it since those do you
do it well I mean they're gonna break in
we're gonna die okay now it's the other
one okay so I've saved up five thousand
to be able to do this I'll put my
guardian down over there I think I got
like 900 money which way I'm going to go
on under right uh ooh
whatever's easiest to wall off right now
by default that one's left
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna put this great
wall on the other one oh we do not have
eleven okay real just start slapping
things down go for it keep slapping keep
slapping I'm gonna put wall stuff
they've broken through a jig this will
give them what they deserve
okay here we go there's gonna be there's
gonna be bad we gonna get bad we're
gonna get a whole lot bad before it gets
a whole lot good we could I've seen you
do it do it unchanged don't let them
throw don't let them throw don't let
them throw don't let them true we're
good we're good we're good
good call good call I forgot about the
unchain what's it happen to me did you
fall I musta I'm getting dirty during
that that unchain the last a long time
we didn't need all that we're they're
all dead now okay it looks like they're
going to come out both of the other side
so they're going to come out bolt it
once over there
so that other side should be trapped up
enough that we don't really need it we
will fire fiend warlocks yes please okay
I wish I could repair this cute though
okay just remember not to stand on them
yeah yeah I'm going to pepper the top
one if you want to pepper the bottom one
huh
I'm dying I don't know why what honey oh
[ __ ] I walked in ice blinked backwards
okay retreat to the trap area yeah I got
a fallback you standing on the thing
okay back up back up back up all the way
to the all the way to the the the
guardian
and we've got this handled all right all
dead
we're good I think we want it we won
hell yeah whoa
like magic maybe you want to go gloating
there channel I'm gonna go gloating
there channel
mr. blundin I don't understand this game
dude that looks right
I liked out in the middle of my
character like everything froze okay all
right I'm not that wasn't oh okay all
right I was like oh I took the least
amount of damages good for you man
congratulation on stirrers who after you
guys you don't got it
I always forget about the thing no I
common dumb but they did no damage to
any of you guys no they did it was it
was a bit of a problem issues I died
acts did but mine isn't hot yet who is
placing down all those slows me [ __ ]
dude ha ha ha no fear no 17 slows all it
was destroy them we just like less than
very good question to the games we're
having a chill time just like talking
and comparing boob sizes and stuff yeah
we got week I might be come on guys my
boobs are obviously the best boobs you
don't have boobs yeah that's true yeah
talking about I have some sweet tits
not really flaps bro I got some luscious
BAPS you're you're a flat-chested [ __ ]
oh oh oh okay okay not gonna be all over
okay
best ostracize yourself to general chat
for that one oh [ __ ] okay here I feel
Bernier him okay
just say something other than okay just
okay alright that's okay
good yeah what's yeah good yeah good
okay [ __ ] some good-lookin [ __ ]
don't who even give this [ __ ]
[Music]
sabotage they're coming through this way
first which way we want to guide them be
that is requests a lot of walls to move
them out of here yeah well I think the
obvious choice is to the obvious choice
is to run them in a way that they would
match up with the other hallway so yeah
rolling off right here yeah well off
this one we don't touch that and then
eventually walk over here with me we'll
wall off for the other guys
we will wall off this this area here
this area here so that they have to go
this way to join up with the other path
you know what I mean yeah that makes the
most sense to me that's a long way to
work here yeah so in the meantime just
[ __ ] spam up because this is a big
area douche did you even ready are you
the one holding it up yep douche here
they come
oh it's fast ease
Oh their their lips their lips bruh
they're lit BAM
so far so good
oh we've been slowed alright just watch
these kobolds if they're going to the
Guardian doesn't stop them they're going
to be a bit of a pain they're coming
through the other side now okay so I'm
going to place down my long wall but I
don't think it's going to be enough so
you're going to need to if you have this
small one it's just right here look at
down here get down here we're just going
to block off here and then they'll have
to go through this and back to connect
to the long-haul
so it'll fight it off up here to make
them go back around through the other
Guardian but I wouldn't bother some of
them will anyway I'd rather not waste
money on the walls money money money
that sweet combo money ho wait oh they
came the other way they must have
summoned something [ __ ] they did [ __ ] we
got a lot how do they get so many boss
minions I don't know either way they're
dying but our Guardian might not be able
to stop this we're in a bit of a spot of
bother here how did they get this ready
boss minion walk has been copla my god
yeah that sucked I don't know they have
you been sending your dudes over to
their team I fit something yes send them
every time yeah but ok that's fine they
took more damage than we did all right
this is good is good ok this is fine do
they break our no they did not all right
so they're going to come through both
now now we got to really fill this place
out with some traps
ok here they come a buttload of them
whoo
metric buttload incoming okay focus on
the Cobell oh we did it
Hey oh good cuz we were about to lose
yeah we were really close to losing
how in the hell man I don't know that
was thing it's too big I think that's an
end for three people because there's no
way that two could have done that well
oh yeah
even with a good stretch here we were
it's good thing you lost cuz we were
just about to yeah we got [ __ ] roll
y'all god yeah we are possible is round
two yeah how did you get some you is so
many bosses you guys sent out like
everything I don't know I got fire
elementals as a consumable yeah daddy
that's a really tough one to beat
yeah we did he wrecked our guardian we
chose wrong choke points and then we
left ourselves a back door that was
about it yeah yeah that was awful I
don't know we didn't choose that choke
points but somehow it didn't matter
anyway there were so many of them yay oh
boy I don't know how's like banana miss
out outro